don't we all get happy when somebody
Embraces Islam how many of us have the
time to dedicate to teaching them Salah
for the first time ever they are left in
the dark without any guidance you are
the reason for people like Michael like
Katrina like Trisha like me start to
pray five times a day
[Music]
that's all due to your donations
brothers and sisters we only need 100
people to give £100 £100 can help teach
10 to 30 people learn how to praise Sal
and memorize Al fa for the first time
ever not only that these reverts will be
teaching their families their wives
their daughters and their sons to learn
how to praise Salah all because of your
donations the prophet Muhammad s. wasam
said when you die all your Deeds come to
an end except three ongoing charity
beneficial knowledge and a righteous
child who prays for you not only is your
donation and ongoing charity but also an
ongoing beneficial knowledge click the
link in the description below and donate
now we're live yeah yeah we're live I
was just doing some I was just doing
some fundraising while you guys come for
this project so you know the one I was
talking to about yesterday yeah you have
an one yeah I've got one like it's it's
here I can give you one as well because
I know you're you're new to praying as
well and you've just you said you just
you know Sur fa now yeah uh nearly is
helping me he's helping good good no
that's good this is good I think my
pronunciation is okay it be good man it
took me quite a bit as well I can
remember when I first came to Islam okay
we've got 900 people watching what is
this so so the Salah plus project is
something actually Muhammad hij we found
it five years ago this project is
something new because it was just more
General doubt was me Muhammad hijab Adan
Rashid Muhammed we started off as like a
movement just given da which we do in
Speakers Corner but we launched this
project about a year and a half ago uh
so um this is basically because we
realize it's it's really difficult for
new Muslims when they come to Islam when
it comes to Salah because it's like so
much bro like how do I pray there's a
lot put your toe back properly or when
to put exctly yeah exactly and then you
got you got your unles who come and tell
you in the Masjid oh don't do this don't
it's so daunting it's likeo I don't even
know how to pray now you're bloody
having a guide at me my hand should be
here or don't do this so as a new Muslim
I could remember 11 years ago when I
first learned how to pray I know how
difficult it was so launching this
project I'm a trustee so I'm I'm a
volunteer I just I volunte I don't get
paid for this so the the team are doing
an amazing job so these prayer mats all
they do is just that if you accept Islam
you can start praying immediately why
because you just put this in front of
you and it shows you the movement it
shows you the transliteration of what to
say so you can start praying immediately
and we know for example something we
didn't talk about yesterday in your life
is that we talk about like food
nutrition when it comes to like I I'm I
do a lot of Sports boxing uh jogging uh
you know um I'm trying to cut down
youing Ramadan too yes I I to me I
believe it's it's a thing in the mind
sneo to me four years ago because I do
jogging every week two times a week yeah
so I do about 4K to 5K jogging so I can
remember it was a 19 hour 19 and a half
hour fast this was 3 years ago yeah so
it was a long hours so about half an
hour before I would call for a jog and I
thought you know what I haven't eaten
I'm I'm proper weak let me I'll do I'll
do 2K jog instead of a 4K so I started
jogging so I did onek I'm feeling good I
did 2K said bro I feel good I did 3K I
did 4K I did 5K bro I don't usually do
5K bro I felt and I thought to myself
you know what bro this all in the mind
just because I was not eating I was
thinking I'm weak we our bodies are not
creating to eat all the time bro when
you're fasting it actually renews your C
so to me I noticed it's all in the mind
so now I had my boxing TR training last
Friday and my coach was like sh take it
bit easy what time like an hour no no 9
in the morning so I had eight hours to
to to break my fast no water the whole
time I don't know I when I box I get
like I SW I look like I jumped on the
pool okay alhamd you know with me one
thing it maybe it might be specific to
me I don't get firsty I don't really get
that firsty so I did my training uh uh
huh I did my training in the morning
9:00 a.m. and my coach was like she go a
bit ligh today I said no do 10 rounds of
skipping boom then we'll do the pad work
boom then do a little circuit and then
he was coming down and he saw me on the
stair Master he's like brother are you
okay I was like no I'm good man I
believe it's in the mind bro I just
genely believe it's in the mind and when
it comes to training you see khabib or
some of them like when when they fight
they're fasting bro even some of them
playing football they're fasting so to
me bro which is very important another
thing sneak off for me like what I
learned was having that intimate
relationship with Allah so when it comes
to Allah we think we need to go to Allah
when we're stuck or we're going through
a difficulty
the sah the companions of the Prophet
peace be upon him they would go and ask
Allah's guidance when they're picking
clothes so they were thinking okay I've
got white color fob or green color fob
both oh yeah you know what they say you
might find they say oh Allah allow me to
find allow me to pick the one that has
more blessing for me and you thinking to
yourself something so little but but
that's the relationship that head bro
that Allah was to that for them to go to
for anything and everything do you get
it so to me it's really really profound
so just coming back this project like I
said before like you know we're just
teaching people how to pray Salah we
have these mats that we send out for
free so you can go to Salah plus.com
you're a new Muslim or even there's born
Muslims who are ashamed of learning how
to pray yeah you order it we send it to
you yeah and if you want an instructor
so me d and a couple of brothers and we
have a sisters team if you want to learn
how to pray we teach you over Zoom so
we've had PE sisters in Jamaica there
was a sister who accepted Islam
b r far yeah yeah so we we we taught how
to pray uh online if you're in London we
teach you so that's what the project is
about I was just doing the fundraising
but you know I was thinking to do the
topic today I was going to make it uh
you're looking to get married aren't you
sneako insh come
on so so to me I've got a project I've
been working on for quite a bit time
it's called my marriage documentary so
it's me documenting when I first came to
Islam my journey to finding my wife you
you're married I'm married yeah yeah
yeah so it's my documentary of me as a
Orthodox Muslim because we don't do
dating we don't do none of the Haram
stuff yeah so it's me trying trying to
find my wife so I documented it like
everything you know when I have marriage
meetings I'll I'll Rec like if there's
permission obviously we don't show you
filmed your marriage meetings so some of
them some of them there we filmed it I
talk about okay I met this sister this
meeting the dad and the brother yeah
yeah there's one actually there was
there was a really nice guy like an
uncle I went to he really appreciat that
I like the fact that you came to me and
asked for my permission so I talk about
my experience for all that like he talk
me like good three four years yeah
you're probably normalize an
uncomfortable situation say that you
you're normalizing an uncomfortable
somewh situation exactly exctly I'm not
really sure how to approach that exactly
exactly I'm kind of just putting it off
and trying to say my be exactly so I
know where you was at so I would like to
share my experience with you this a
great topic I think we want we want sneo
to find his wife are you married no what
we're gonna get two brothers
married how are you not married brother
honestly I'm focusing on my goals right
now are you sure you sure the sisters
are I think the sisters are blinded
where you're from brother they're not
they're not they're not looking they're
loing the G to much they've been sending
in applications but I haven't reviewed
them yet okay I see that oh you haven't
reviewed them yet okay you know what I
think today's topic should be here is
how to find your wife in in in in in a
proper way because it's not easy I know
but to me it was it was it was nightm
bro like I went through some Madness bro
well I got catfished yeah but it wasn't
a man it was actually real woman it was
a real woman but I didn't see her but
she she used she was did you
say
no no it can be these days you could
expect anything I was speaking to a
trans Hindu two days ago yeah not for
marriage so anyways guys if you're
watching this the donation link is there
you guys can donate as we talk today's
topic we're gonna have insh I think it's
important we'll have hijab Ste as well
he's got some funny stories bro he's got
some funny stories what was the ca story
so you shut up in did she not fit in her
job bro I did not meet her ever she was
using pictures that was not of her so
every time I would say because I'm not
about this dating business so to me it's
like look I need to get to know you for
a little bit to a certain amount after I
need to speak to your father bro just I
need if you don't let me speak to your
father I that's Al let me ask something
but how do you even get pictures I
thought you're not supposed to see her
like no you can pictur of her in aab
like I'm gonna give you some cheat codes
here are you ready for the sneaker so I
follow the opinion that H Hiles yeah is
that when you okay so this is how it
works so let's say I'm speaking to a
sister and I'm interested in marriage so
obviously there's some questions you
need to ask first to get the gist if
you're compatible so once you've done
that obviously not prolonging like
speaking to for weeks no no no just a
couple of days ask some basic questions
let's see if we're in the same uh
wavelength and then after that I say
look I want to speak to your dad to ask
his permission so his dad will say okay
you know what thanks for coming to me
okay I will get my son so anytime you
guys want have a meeting or whatever for
that matter um you guys can get to know
each other now as you getting to know
her and things get a bit serious you
have every right to ask for a picture
the prophet peace be upon him a man came
that he was saying that he was getting
to know someone for marriage and he said
to have you seen her he said no he said
see her for you might see something that
will incline you to to marry her you you
are allowed to see her that's why we
believe in Islam you can cover
everywhere except your hands and your
face now the schol of thought that I
follow they take this Hadith and they
say hold on a second we can take a few
things from this so some say you can see
like
um even you can even see the hair I
don't know if you heard of this yeah you
can if she if she wants to only if
you're propositioning for marriage if
you're proposition for marriage and it's
at the stages where it's getting a bit
serious and you're like you know what do
you mind if I see you with your hair
yeah right it's it's it's the opin the
opinion the always quite a strong sneak
I'll keep it down yeah okay what would
you do if if she uh she was bald or she
had if she's bald there's always a
Solutions U there's always someone out
there for her so it's
not no no no no it really it really
depends but I'll be honest with you
yeah which one this one it's not working
no no you gota be careful this the one
away from it look he's got his fist
ready
already okay let me know if it's working
yeah so yeah um you can see certain like
for example some say you can see up to
you know like the forearm or the carves
because it gives you an idea of her body
mass if that makes sense yeah yeah you
can see like from here from here so she
can wear certain clothing that give you
an idea and a gist of how she made look
CU you it's in front of her family as
well right no of course yeah yeah no no
not not just you did you do that so when
you met you get to see like a wrist okay
there was a situation where there was a
Yen a sister that's what it is yeah so
there was a a situ ation where there was
a Yemen sister I was getting into an off
of marriage in Birmingham and I traveled
I met the family and I requested if I
can see her without without hijab and
yeah she came and to me I'll be honest
like to me it was just like it just and
it's interesting because the prophet PE
upon him said see for something that
might incline you further and I and that
to me like was like okay like I was okay
attract you saw some good hair but yeah
yeah obviously but you know but you
know Chase one two have no fear the
Warner is here oh I like that have no
fear one you should get t-shirts like
that you don't have headphones
no no his one not coming through no
problem we can share our mic no no no no
if not come to here yeah come come so
guys okay aldah which camera do we look
at brother no camera we look at each
other yeah we're having like a nice chat
in So yeah so you can you can see
certain stuff like cuz at the end of the
day you know one thing like for example
when we come from that background yeah I
know is yeah cuz we can like talk to
girls on the street you get it it
depends like I the background that I
came from like not that I'm R I'm trying
to praise it was like you know bro you
don't you don't know nothing about
lowering your gaze yeah there's no
lowering your gaze you're chatting to
girls left right center so you're coming
with baggage so um that's why it's like
there's certain traits that you need to
work on Etc because not lowering the
Gaze can be quite problematic and it's
one of the hardest things for us men you
know that's why when Allah subh says in
the Quran that he created man weak one
scholar said imagine how weak man is
that he looks at something that he
cannot gain and he gets nothing from it
except you know just just making you
more horny or whatever and you're still
looking that's how weak a man is do you
get what I'm trying to say so to us
obviously roolling the gates is very
important but yeah you can you can see
man like have you had any Mar marriage
meetings yeah yeah yeah okay what's
what's what's what are the obstacles
that you say it's
like the all things that you're a bit
like I don't know man I think going from
from what I'm from
it's hard to get to know someone you
know I think uh just how much you can
speak to the girl before it's considered
dating you know how how much you can get
to know or um in a in a respectful way
before it's like okay well maybe you
should just get married already like I'm
used to I'm used to dating and exactly
yeah it's just completely different it's
completely different and then and just
hear you hearing you explain like
looking at an ankle or a wrist to try to
get idea of what the rest of her body is
like is like um I can't help but think
that's like silly you know like trying
you're looking at her ankle thick and
like how big are her you know like but
yeah it's a whole it's a whole different
it is it is but you know you know with
this matter it's very important yeah
it's like again we say we was talking
about having trust in Allah yeah when I
look let me be honest I went through a
lot of obstacles and difficulties
throughout my marriage Journey lot bro I
got like talking to catfish to time
wasters to being rejected by racism by
the way yeah getting to know certain
culture was a white girl no no no no
these these were like I don't want to
give cuz some people get upset I don't
want to go into where they were from
yeah but I'll be rejected because I'm
not from that part of the world yeah um
so to me it was very difficult but one
thing that I learned was this yeah when
you stay persistent to Allah and you
stay true to his word and you do not
involve or indulge in Haram and even if
you indulge in Haram you repent yeah
once you do that bro like when I met my
wife and like with my wife like
obviously um I didn't I I did speak to
her and as I was getting serious I did
ask for her like to see if I can see
without hijab and yeah she like she sent
me a picture I saw it and from there
onwards I'll be honest with you bro my
wife was like a like you know some
sisters I was getting to know for
marriage Etc bro like I was say yeah
they were a seven out of 10 when I met
my wife my wife was a 20 out of 10 for
me for me so what it's as if Allah was
saying to me listen Ali you went through
a lot of Madness you could have gone
about the Haram way you could have gone
link them date them commit Zena you
didn't you didn't do that you stayed
firm here's your gift here's your reward
and to my wife obviously I don't want to
talk too much because I know I I don't
agree with social media couples that
that make their marriage seem as if
something is not and it gives this false
perception of reality to people I
believe it's it's um it's not right you
know you know get this coua everything
looks so amazing Mar marriage has ups
and downs keep your life private yeah
but to me bro let me be honest when you
stick true to Allah subhana tala Allah
gives you what you want bro I'm telling
you and you know when it comes to prayer
one thing that you need to know when it
comes to imagine you go to a King so you
have this King that invites you to his
kingdom he owns the whole earth and he
comes to you and you he says to you sneo
what do you want from me and you go I
want an
apple what do you think he'll do to you
probably give it to me no he'll kill you
bro for an apple yeah you know why cuz
he'll be like you're insulting me you're
coming to my kingdom I own everything
and you want an apple you're coming to
my kingdom and you you're you're
basically ins it's like a you're
degrading me in front of do you get what
I'm trying to say ask me for something
ask me for a a bloody building ask me do
you get I'm trying to say because he's
the king if you ask him for Apple he's
going to think this guy's degrading me
so like when you go to Allah ask for
whatever you want bro when you're making
du I would be very specific in my
prayers when it comes to what kind of a
woman I want I'm talking body parts to
like I would be in detail I want this
kind of
hair me me I'm same goes with you bro
bro you have to you have let me tell
something you have to be bro go into
detail this is Allah bro you know what
crazy I saw in your face right now you
visualize like a Spanish like like
Latino woman I the thing is like you
know you know she has she has to have
something else I might break her you
know I'm big no no no no no no exactly
but that's that's your type so like to
me to me to me I have a specific look
yeah and by the way look to me I have a
specific that I looked for yeah okay so
there's many people I've met for
marriage a lot okay I was looking for
three four years okay it was getting
Peak yeah especially when you live in
the west bro you can't have sex but
outside of marriage bro it is peak in
summertime everyone's half naked bro so
lower your gaze even on the floor
there's FNA there's a floor in the F
when I look down I have to look to the
sky to see nothing yeah okay I have to
walk look into the to the sky so it was
really really Peak but the point is this
bro is that I usually put mirrors on my
shoes bro we need get married straight
away brother you're something else so
yeah I would say be very specific with
the prayer and Allah will give you what
you want so when it comes to this stuff
of the seen like for example okay I
don't know how her body looks I don't
know do you get what I'm trying to say
and it's it's kind of risky how does she
look with with that hijab do you get it
some some girls look really good with
hijab when hijab comes off you're
like okay it's no it looks it's mad it's
like like you know you look totally
different well some of them they are
different their hand color is different
to their face bro right you're thinking
bro your head your face color is
different to your hand because of the
makeup three four years is a long time
to be looking for a wife well I have
been praying for it I don't know like in
Islam you're supposed to like speak
about what you pray for but even when
when for um that was like pretty
consistent but I wasn't like I'm not in
a rush you know was just something I was
just saying that when it's ready I I do
trust in a lot that when I'm ready or
when he's ready it's gonna happen so
100% that's true you should it's it's
good that you submit to that you know
but you need to understand that your
body also is going to start acting on
your like do you get it so it's good
that you have that uh but once if you
are a man like for example when you come
to Islam and you're not going having sex
outside of marriage um then your body's
going to start be like you know what
look you need to start looking and
that's why I say it's very important
actually I even tell men when you're
getting to know a sister for marriage
Etc make sure you that marriage meeting
happens when you're not overly Hy why
because you know as you might rush into
a decision yeah because it it it clouds
your decision- making factors you're the
most impulsive when you're exactly so so
it's very important like some people
might think oh my gosh look it's a
reality us men we're visual creatures so
make sure that you're you're you're a
bit calm so you can make a rational
decision CU I I know a lot of brothers
don't we all get happy when somebody
Embraces Islam how many of us have the
time to dedicate to teaching them Salah
for the first time ever they are left in
the dark without any guidance you are
the reason for people like Michael like
Katrina like Trisha like me start to
pray five times a day that's
[Music]
F all due to your donations brothers and
sisters we only need 100 people to give
£00 £100 can help teach 10 to 30 people
learn how to praise Salah and memorize
Al fa for the first time ever not only
that these reverts will be teaching
their families their wives their
daughters and their sons to learn how to
praise Salah all because of your
donations the prophet Muhammad s. wasam
said when you die all your Deeds come to
an end except three ongoing charity
beneficial knowledge and a righteous
child who prays for you not only is your
donation an ongoing charity but also an
ongoing beneficial knowledge click the
link in the description below and donate
now we you I know that place yeah no no
no there there they have one in SoHo
they have one in Nice Bridge so we'll go
to one of them we'll see because this
one you can't reserve it's like a cafe
it's like one of those kind of it's nice
so we should have space they've also got
enl there so be in mind it's Monday
today he won't be busy it's it's Monday
today bear in mind it won't be that busy
today's Monday it's not like a Friday
Saturday if it was a Friday Saturday oh
mad thing yeah the guys at in in East
London they done a good job of like the
food was good East London where did you
oh you're talking about yesterday oh
yeah good very good yeah they know how
to take care of us in a good good man oh
uh the place that we were at yeah yeah
yeah
yeah what's your favorite Cuisine you
yeah that's good question I love steak
oh you like steak okay I like wag steak
if you like that bro we should get I
know a place called steak on the green
very nice yeah maybe six Ste
tomorrow or later tonight yeah pretty
twice and I only once and or twice in
the past two days he hasn't been eating
s really same same bro sleeping either
11: p.m. boom and then I just wake up
fudge and go back to sleep I don't do
so
yeah it's tough to waiting until Maring
I glad we're not on the stream but like
not committing zenos that's a huge one
for me bro it is it is it is it's it's
it's um this is this is why you know
with this kind of stuff here let me be
honest when I first came to Islam this
is one of the things I like I fear the
most like going back to my old way
especially with like girls and we knew
you know it's very interesting because
in in Surah tal Allah says that if you
fear me I will give you a way out from
places you can never imagine well your
are scratched up you know yeah I know
you know what happened I I finished
training it was in my pocket it fell on
the floor and I stepped on it so I had
to send the other glasses off they're
get a new lens and I'm going to send
these off so yeah so yeah when it when
it comes to this bro I was very
frightened bro going back to girls and
all that kind of stuff but W let me be
honest you genuinely man if you fear
Allah you know it's as if someone
sedated me bro for a year and a
half when I first came to Islam yeah I
got into the da I just said oh like I
just hate this sin and just keep me away
from it bro W I felt as if I went in a
coma for about a year and a half and I
and and I remembered this about a year
into the da and I thought to myself man
I used I used to have this problem and
then it's just as if bro just reset my
brain what did you say that dawa keeps
you away from sin bro bro look I got
basically what happened is I was a new
Muslim I got into the da I was I was
thinking fearing that I'm going to go
back to my old ways with the girls and
all kind of stuff yeah what I know is
just I got into the da things happen
really fast about a year into it then I
thought to myself I had this problem
like you know of girls and stuff like
that da bro look that what keeps me away
from sins bro that what keeps me in
check you know why because if I'm not
doing D I don't know what I'm doing so
when you're involved with the kind of
stuff you have to be around people that
do it do you get it you have to read
books pertaining to it and you're you're
involved in da in the streets you get it
so Allah always gives you a way out it's
hard don't get it twisted it's one of
the most hardest things you can ever go
through but bro Allah will definitely
give you a way
out for now swap wires so we share that
M that's fine so we share that mic yeah
just let's just that's fine that's fine
can we let's just go live yeah just swap
out the
ca this cable yeah just take one why
that is not working so then let's just
put this down and just put that in the
middle and they use it how you going in
I just move the table oh wouldn't that
reach you yeah that's what I'm saying
wouldn't that reach
you yeah I like
that would that reach yeah right here
yeah is that okay are we live right now
I I have no
idea oh thank you
for yeah I've been thank you very much
oh
man hey I didn't say anything nothing
nothing I'm going to say the same thing
anyway now okay so we still live how
many people
watching okay that's fine I just want to
guys at the meantime while we're doing
this I just want to give you guys a
reminder about something a project that
Salam was started actually from Muhammad
hijab myself was the founders all
together but we've launched this project
which is the Salah plus project sneak
here um and um obviously he noticed how
hard it is when you're learning how to
pray Salah how difficult and you're
still learning still learning yeah and I
know how difficult it is for myself as
well when hurt CU you have to like BR
sit comfortably sit no no no you don't
have to do that bro people always make
it seem like you have to it's it's a you
can do it you're not sinful if you don't
so sit in a place you're comfortable I
know how it is bro sitting in a specific
position your legs hurt and then you
don't like praying you don't want that
feeling sit comfortably bro sit it's
hard to focus on praying when I'm
thinking about my toes thank you do you
see what I mean so I know where you're
coming from because I was there did you
get it bro sit comfortably wherever
you're comfortable bro on your like left
buttocks or your right or you just
I put my legs like that like flat you
get what I'm trying to say so bear that
in mind so guys if you're watching this
Salah plus.com you can order your guided
prayer mat if you are new Muslim the the
prayer M there not only that we have
guided Salah instructors so if somebody
wants to learn how to pray Salah I was
talking about sister Katan from Jamaica
what do you say m
CL yeah so we've got a people ordering
this around the world last year we
talked about up to 10,000 people
directly or indirectly how to pray Salah
you can book a Salah instructor order
your guide a prayer mat and not only
that we this project around Europe to
open Salah hubs so they'll be dedicated
plac in mass and community centers
anyone that wants to learn how to play
Salah they can come and we have Quran
instructors who will teach you Surah fa
and you said you slowly getting there
with the Surah fa exactly so sneer knows
the struggle I know the struggle but
yeah we're going to get back into topic
it's about finding sneo and the Warner
wife in yeah okay so we're going to get
some advice from yeah that's what we're
doing
today
is that what
we hey it looks like he woke up it's
like expression shot right bro one
second I just remember bro take a pillow
man sorry I'm taking you what do I do
more comfortable is that
comfortable oh okay so so hijab how was
the marriage seeking process for you can
you just is the story of punching your
leg no listen let me tell you something
I had a different life to you guys I was
obviously U born and raised as Muslim so
I didn't have a Jia frankly in terms I
didn't really have I didn't before I got
married I didn't get involved in
promiscuity because he he born Muslim
like yeah but even then let's say there
were other things I mistakes I made but
it was that wasn't one of them actually
ald so alhamdulillah that was uh I just
got married um I got first married got
married to someone that was in my school
I got married at the age of 20 years old
and been married for 11 years got three
kids you know yeah um but let me tell
you something look the marriage seeking
process is now people talk about
arranged marriage like I was talking to
some a non-believer one time and he was
talking to us about arranged marriages
yeah yeah he was like how you guys do
like arranged marriages and stuff yeah
and I was like well you can move you can
move that back we go different cable is
it good now yeah is it working okay
perfect all right
yes course the service is much less
here the cable's not even on BR look at
this look at this thing what
this industrial estate and the dungeon
that we've come in here and the cable's
not working I thought we were going to
get killed in that elevator yeah
assassination over there yeah yeah we do
we do a couple of kidnappings a year
that's right works now all right so what
I was going to say is that
disbeliever yeah he was telling me about
arranged marriage and how do you Muslims
do arranged marriage I said listen let
me tell you something yeah I said um I
was on the tube underground underground
time and I saw match.com that was the
that was the advert on it
match.com I said what is match.com he
said it's a website which sets people up
I said How's it do it so you know you
put your whatever it is and then it
arranges a marriage I said so you guys
believe in arranged marriage as well you
just got a different way you're doing
exactly just let hey I
do Subway just helped you
huh but they have a misconception that
arranged marriages is forc like you
don't like in Islam like I was talking
about the I follow the opinion that you
are allowed to see the woman with
without the hijab yeah and some you can
see the you know the you don't follow
the opinion say you can see the whole
body naked
no that's a very minority opinion that's
a wrong opinion yeah yeah but that that
even that says that that's say you you
can like sneak and look at her like yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's yeah that's what
that's sneak that's not the I'll keep it
I'll say with the rest for now the name
yeah exactly so yeah I was just telling
you like for example thing is not even
controversial no it's some for some
people it is for some people when I see
they're like what where did you get this
opinion from it's this and for me like
there was an instance where I was
getting to know a Yen sister from
marriage in Birmingham and I went to the
family's house and I said can I see she
came with no hijab yeah yeah so the
thing is it's it's it's normal but you
know like I was saying to you before
sneo like it comes to coming from that
Jah and to explain that word J is for
example time of ignorance I want to say
Z
yeah period a hot girl summer yeah it's
the time of ignor Subhan Allah before
Islam so uh when when it comes that it
was really really hard because when you
think about you're living a lifestyle
with no Islam you're talking to girls
left right center it's it's Happy Days
bro you're not lowering your gaze what
you're looking at everyone and anything
yeah because you don't know this concept
of lowering your GS for what do you get
it you're speaking to girls left right
Cent Etc yes you can talk about it comes
with pros of yeah you get the r you know
how to talk to girls you got the
confidence those things yes you get that
there might be a pro for that you learn
how to talk to promiscuous women you're
not learning how to speak to good women
exactly but what that does is that bu
that huge difference true and actually
when you when you come around a good
conservative woman like you kind of get
really anxious and Frozen you you freeze
up just like let me tell you something
sneak you should find very interesting
when I came to Islam what I did is all
that that's very interesting it it is it
is but I have a real life experience
that happened to me yeah is the
following I came from that jilia s
speaking the girls left it just it's
just happy days you get it you build a a
confidence to yourself okay Don't
Lie by the way I love the way you guys
said GS like it sounds like you guys are
talking about something else you know so
yeah exactly so so to me obviously when
I say this it's not something to be
proud of be ashamed of it's just to give
you guys an thing so when you come back
this is one thing we make a mistake from
yeah and you've mentioned this so it
shows it's not I was thinking is it only
me so when you come and you get to know
hijabi for marriage you it's like I
resetted my factory settings so I was
like you know what all this you know the
r or how to speak the girls I said no no
no this is a whole different ball game
it doesn't apply like all the tactics
and the stuff you've learned from
sleeping with 50 women let me tell you
this here let me tell you this when I
was getting to know certain sisters for
marriage you know what I realized
they're all wired the same the only
difference is one where a mint the one
is a when I'm in wiring there's a deep
inner wiring of a woman that does not
change so I realized me moving in a
certain way and thinking you know what
let's go about this you know like in a
pure there's nothing wrong with it but
you need that Halal game it works Hal
game you need that I'm just let you know
I'm just letting you know bro you need
that so don't let go of it in the sense
where look look
look sign up to my course under $1,000
use discount code sneak
54 so so it does work sne in the way
because why every woman wants a man
that's confident who is you get I'm
trying to say I just realized uh I
realized the difference just now is that
most of game uh Haram game if you will
yeah it's all a lie because you're
you're selling this dream and you're
kind of like pretending to that you're
pretending that you're gonna commit to a
girl and you're making her think that
that making her feel comfortable for the
fact that she's gonna give up her body
for a night so is that what is that what
how you do it we need to understand how
the Haram game works just for well yeah
because yeah as a as a player or
whatever like you're you're not trying
to commit to the girl so you're selling
her this idea like oh okay we'll get
sushi next week or like we'll go on a
date and then you know like oh I have
work in the morning I need to call you
an Uber I'll see you later today and
then you never see her again so the
whole thing is like it's kind of sleazy
you kind of feel like a car salesman
yeah that that aspect of it we don't
we're not talking about that we're
talking about those the the the
experience that you had there the
confidence that it's given you as a man
and who you are because you need to
understand you need to have a certain
demeanor and the way you talk and the
way you approach that a woman finds it
interesting that part transferable
definitely transferable so we're not
talking about the lies the only thing
maybe you can maybe you can lie about I
don't know is maybe if she you know how
to make comfortable but maybe the only
thing that you might it's more about the
sins and stuff like what you don't you
don't want to you don't want to you can
lie about that as a man or a woman yes
yes yes exactly exactly so yeah a woman
who's has had like let's say for example
she's done zner and she doesn't want
anyone to know about that and she knows
that if she goes and tells a man about
this that he will not marry her or
whatever it may be she doesn't need to
reveal that sin really
but what if he asks her and she lies to
him well she's not I don't I don't
personally think that she's s him if she
does that okay but finds out later that
you know what if he doesn't look does he
have a right look look this this is what
I find really on this point bro there
there is classic uh scholarship which
says that she can lie about okay but
what if he wants a virgin what if he
says I want a virgin yeah yeah well I
mean you don't have to look if you want
a virgin there's no way of finding up
100% sure is there true so you have to
look at the you have to look at the
things which make you think that this
person that I'm going to be married to
is a virgin like let's see the family
that she comes from stuff whatever if
you go through all the checklist and you
know that she's a person who's like from
her demeanor she doesn't seem like
musculous woman from her family she
seems like she's like all the things in
the right place yet it turns out she's
had this experience and there's
something outside of controlable it is
it is it is but like let's be honest
let's let's be fair here yeah like okay
if a woman wants a virgin man she wants
a man who's never been with her woman
before there's no actual way of her now
yeah it's possib and and and and and if
he says look I don't want to but you
need to understand for a man and a woman
different things matters different
things matter I I would argue that there
is a way for a woman to tell if a man's
a virgin because a man that's a virgin
he he behaves completely differently
really than a man that's experienced not
in the Muslim World am Mike from what I
noticed I notice a lot of like I would
say in the zena world if a guy's a
virgin he's really like like acting
autistic and nervous and stuff like that
but I noticed like Muslim men who are
proud of that because in the Zen world
it's something that you're ashamed of
like when a guy's a virgin it's
something that you don't want to tell
anybody because it's like a badge of
honor to lose it but in the Muslim world
like even my friend that um I don't want
to say is I don't want to expose people
but a lot of these people like young
Muslims here that are virgin they're
like kind of proud of it and that was
weird to hearing the first time like it
was kind of like a flex that they that
they never committed Zen before it
doesn't change their their demeer if you
if you're on your Dean I think that's
that's a good point as well bro because
like I'll be honest growing up it was
like an initiation for young people I
remember my classmates about mentioning
any names like they were all it was it
was it was seen as a badge of honor it
was embarrassing if you didn't have
intercourse at a certain age bro exactly
it was embarrassing but for me it wasn't
embarrass no one put me down for it cuz
they knew what I was trying what life I
was trying to live right it's true but
but the thing is you know what it is
it's very important because I was
watching a video yeah and it was of
these two girls who were basically
reading the story of this this guy
married this girl and then he found out
that she's had a promiscuous background
Muslim girl and then three months before
they got married she was actually
committed zner so now obviously you
might be sinful for going and spying on
that matter that's not permissible yeah
but the matter is that the woman were
there bro finishing the guy why you why
are you stalking her for it's her past
but let's just flip this around because
they say oh you shouldn't judge it okay
no problem what if a guy is getting to
know a girl for marriage yeah and this
and this sister asks him do you want to
get do you want to get a second wife and
he says yeah which woman would marry him
they would judge him based on his future
but when he judges a based on a past
he's wrong so the point is this for
different for us we judge a Woman by her
past not I'm saying we should go and
like when I mean judge I'm saying the
decision to say I would like to marry or
not you have a go at a man for doing
that but you are the same woman that if
a man if you came to let's say you get
into no sneak off a marriage and you say
sneak by sneak are you looking to get
married again and he says yeah you're
going to start thinking oh my gosh why
not only that if he was to do that while
being married to you and wanted the
second wife your friends will be saying
divorce him divorce him so when it's a
man doing it because of her past he's
bad and he shouldn't but when this you
guys doing it it's okay it's hypocrisy
to me every everyone have preferences
like man can if
want yeah the issue just to make this
point clear because some people will say
like what's the evidence and stuff yeah
yeah because in Islam you're not allowed
to you're not allowed to for a Muslim
person unless you're a non-muslim who's
had a life there's there are exceptions
or you've had the J life whatever but
generally speaking if you are practicing
Muslim and you commit the sin you
shouldn't say yes you shouldn't yes
generally so if that because there's
clear on that yes Scholars have
struggled with two things okay do you be
honest if someone asks you if you
committed a sin fully or do you say
something which is a lie but it's a
lesser of two evils here because there's
two evils there's there's a concept
called the lesser of two evils there's
two evils revealing your sin is an evil
yeah and lying is an evil we accept both
of them evil things so if a woman is to
be asked now like were you promiscuous
in a in a way in a way before and she
says yes uh I was promiscuous now
falling into a sin which she's revealing
her major sins whereas if she said she
lies she's also falling into a sin but
this sin might be less than this one so
that's what these Scholars say I'm sure
some other Scholars say the other things
but that's the opinion that I follow the
second thing isi and this might sound a
bit crude but in Islam the idea of sex
and promiscuity is um is defined in a
very specific way yeah so there's levels
of it yeah um a man having oral sex with
a woman m is not the same as a vaginal
sex or anal sex yeah so for woman does
would it be classified as breaking your
virginity in a strict Islamic way if I'm
not saying anyone this is this is a
major sin still yeah but is it as bad if
someone committed oral sex versus uh
vaginal or anal sex no vaginal or anal
sex have their separate R so the pen
going into the ink has a separate ruling
right so
would would it be fair to say that I've
remained to a certain extent yeah chased
uh if they've done one sin but not the
other it would be so even that is there
a Nuance in high school with the
Christian girls we will call that the
poophole
loophole because it's not technically if
if you sleep with a girl anal leite it's
not technically like real sex so you
know
C it's worse right no it's yeah it's
Haram it's Haram to do that you can't
even do that with your wife yeah it's
completely forbid frankly that's the
only thing that is mentioned
specifically specifically you can't do
you can pretty much do anything else you
know it's very interesting in high
school I remember in sex ed they would
tell girls that hey if you want to keep
your virginity just have them do you you
know like do anal
instead but yeah let's go back to the
topic of uh finding finding uh
yes yeah we can get some cuse but
pertaining to the topic yeah but in the
meantime guys just a remind to you guys
there's a donation and can you put like
a thing um just 100 pounds teaches 10 to
30 people how to pray Salah Salah so
guys if you're watching this we're also
fundraising at the same time with
brother here with sneak mhammed hijab
and the Warner inah we're trying to
teach people how to pray Salah so 100
pounds can teach 10 to 30 people how to
do W how to pray Salah and even we teach
them s
of for new Muslims who do not know so
that's what we're fundraising for
brother sisters the donation link is on
the chat chat of pin it if you want to
ask questions pertaining to this topic
we're discussing discussing now to get
sneako and the Warner married off
inshallah so there got to be a way of
doing it properly like it's no we're
talking about giving them advice not
like getting
them do both okay I don't mind
if why don't we do both yeah what let me
tell what what you look for let me ask
you got email that we can can send all
the the CVS to the yeah I was wonder
where you're saying CVS what is that Mar
CV so I don't know like how should we do
this it's like a cover letter yeah so
she'll tell you what she where she's
from she'll tell you like you know like
uh how old she is she'll tell you like
all the major like bullet points of what
she it's like a CV you got work it's a
marriage one so anything like the stuff
that she looks for let's let's let start
with there marriage CV what do you what
do you what do you look let's start with
what do you look for tell us some things
that you look for in a woman like what
is it that you look for where you're
like okay these are my neoti first so CV
is like I could have an email or like no
you write that imagine imagine you have
in Word document yeah your name how tall
you are your hobbies what you like what
you're looking for your non negotiables
pict and a picture without a picture
it's a waste of time I'm sorry to say I
know many of you are modest and all that
stuff yeah but don't waste our
times see how we GNA judge how we going
to judge you could C your dader into
that whatever if you if you want to be
yeah inshah so let's let's find out
what's what's the how I've been like
kind of doing I don't spend that much
time on it but like if I see a girl that
you know like I'll talk to her a little
bit like a couple messages and then if
it's like I'll try to escalate like okay
can I speak to your brother or speak to
your your father and then okay so has
has has Muslim woman been approaching
you have you been like have tried like
like me if I found if I saw a sister on
Instagram that find like to I would
message her yeah that's what it's been
like just girls on social media see
that's the problem though because okay
like it can get really it can get bad if
you speak uh privately I try to keep it
brief simple no but how so for example
the initiation process yes but in for
example I was I was speaking to some
people about my if I'm not mistaken so
the initiation is thisam alayum sorry I
came across your profile I find a liking
I would like to get to know you from Mar
and I would like to speak to your father
that's exactly can I ask some question
so just some just some not like a it's
best to do it in like in a place public
of course of course yes for examp
especially public figure bro because
let's be frank yeah like you know
sneaker is a big public figure
especially
be it's it's imagine imagine what kind
of Leverage a person has yeah if you're
proposing marriage to them on a on DM
like it can be it can be I I I I I think
you're right when comes to public
figures we need to be care careful
because you know be honest there were
people who were trying to would message
me talk to me in a certain way to to
catch me out yeah so so yeah oh th nio
was talking to me in that way so the
thing is with that I'm very careful but
it has worked but again you have to be
careful especially with public figures
there's nothing wrong with it because
you're approaching in a Halal manner but
you have to be careful business be
business likee yeah exactly exactly
because you want to get to a point where
like okay this is let's talk about it
yeah exactly we just had some we just
had couple meetings you know what I mean
so just to give you guys do theah they
just give some updates Abdullah Ali Just
donated 200
pound BR you know ABD you know ABD Ali
we've got we've got a scoreboard up
there we have like a top donors he gave
total
5,500 yeah and we just
hadic gave 255 us so what that means is
200 200 can help teach 20 to 60 people
how to do how to pray Salah and me can I
donate as well yeah appreciate whenever
you want may Allah bless
you
I'm ring up bro I'm ring uping up so the
donations are coming up we're on our way
to the 27,000 Mark but yeah so sneo with
you so you've had these sister what kind
of how do they approach you we're War it
this well we want to know what he I
started off with him
butne I started off with you first asked
you first and then you change the whole
topic yeah I mean I I don't know I've
never really thought about talking about
this too much but I think it this it
seems modest uh a couple some girls have
messaged me and then we'll speak it it's
pretty much exactly like that like salam
alaikum how are you like where you from
okay like are you married yeah I just
it's very brief like informational we're
not like flirting or something like that
like where are you from are you looking
to get married Bing bam boom uh some
girls that I've um I messag like I know
from from Twitter and I I've
propositioned this one girl and she's I
don't even I have no idea what she looks
like her profile pictures of her and a
burka and she's posting picture of her
of her meals like her cooking and stuff
like that you you you were attracted to
that it's her prayers like just like the
what she was saying was like was
attractive like she was very clearly
very feminine um but you you want to
look you I definitely see her face yeah
I do yeah and you were allowed to buy
that's why I after I she it looked like
her cooking was really good so I wanted
to see what like you know so is that is
that one thing for you the cooking like
what is it for you like is it the
cooking I didn't that wasn't if you
asked me to write something for my
criteria I would not have thought of
that but her meals were looking good
okay one second before we come to your C
I want you to think think I'm gonna come
I'm gonna come back to you think of I'm
gonna come back to I'm going to go to
one think of three things that you
definitely need in a woman yeah I'm
going to come back to you think about it
yeah that's a good question well no
let's go to you so what what is the for
you what is the thing where you're likeo
she must have this or like three things
number one is obedience right obedience
OB he had brother obedience I think any
I think any woman that just looks at you
will be automatically ask obedience yeah
so obedience pure what do you mean by
pure pure like she's not corrupted what
do you mean by that are you talking
about for example like we talked about
virginity are you talking about because
no no but because a a person who has had
promisc past if they repent it's as if
they you get say so what do we mean by
that no no I don't want her to have a
pass okay yeah that's that's that's your
right that's your preference yeah just
as a sister who says I don't want a man
who wants I want the best for myself at
the end day I want the best for myself
for me that's not the best for myself
perfect so you so the first was uh first
is obedience obedience then you want her
to not have a past pure a pure woman you
know that that her her femininity has
been preserved perfect it hasn't been
damaged you know because I believe
through trauma that her
femininity gets damaged so I don't want
a traumatized woman I want a woman that
hasn't been traumatized I want a woman
that has been able to be protected by
her father by her brothers and then
inshallah the father and the brothers
are going to be giving her to me and
then she's going to be under my care in
insh and thirdly anything and third is
there like like beauty Beauty okay
beauty is there a specific look you go
for like is it like a specific color is
it a specific look ethnicity yeah yeah
look it can be like um I I think I
prefer Pakistani I prefer Pakistani uh
that's something I think I would prefer
Pakistani okay so again but I'm open but
I I think my preference will be okay so
for those brother and sister watching
this brother the Warner is not married
sneo is not married so if there are
proposals in a a a decent manner Etc you
are looking to get married in in so
there is insh so going back to sne we're
going to bounce between you two in and
then we'll talk about me and the hijabs
May no no no like before marriage
preferences yeah I know we don't get
killed honest I I don't really have like
I don't have a preference like racially
or so you don't mind racially are you
sure any specific type of girl not
really she I don't want her to be fat I
think like main thing like Fitness is
needs to be important to her so are you
talking about like skinny or you talking
about maybe curvy no Fitness like oh
Fitness yeah she needs to be in shape
like I want like good body fou
percentage like where the that is on her
body I don't really care too much uh I
don't have like when you're asking I'm
trying to like visualize my wife I don't
have an image you don't have an image no
I don't what about what about certain
things where you like like you talked
about cooking is cooking an important
thing for you yeah it's a very important
I think that's a given though that seems
like the bare minimum it's like I like
oh like if a woman wants a husband that
he makes money what kind of food you
like she yeah what kind of food do you
like bro I don't know that girl that I
saw cooking on Twitter I was like it was
like a there some vegetables and the
steak was looking good every day there
was a new meal I didn't even know a lot
of what the meals were but it's like a
good he has to have a variety of meals
good variety yeah that surprise me you
know I don't want to get bored with the
casserole every night okay what are the
things where are red flags for you where
you're like you know what you only give
do you only give two two things but he
said that's the only thing he go yeah
again femininity is very important that
she preserves that and that's like the
the main Forefront I'm tired of like a
lot of women in the west they they think
that in order to be um feminine that
they need to be sorry to Cur a bad b
word you know what I'm talking about
like a boss all this type of thing I'm
really tired of hearing that from from
women so a woman who knows that her
power comes from her femininity she does
needed to act like a man in order to be
powerful there there's there's a lot of
power in in lead into her feminine
nature that it's okay like you know
there's power in being submissive and
having a good man and cooking and
nurturing all those things are are very
important and Powerful under God red
flags I would say before we go to the
red flags yeah we just Abdullah Ali you
got him excited just donated 400
pounds
abdd pound Ali gave 25 years ABD Ali I
said to him I said to him I'll jump in
that because I do ice Challenger year if
anybody donates 500 I jump in the ice bu
okay I said if anybody donates 1,000
pound I jump in the ice B with my
clothes on not today though okay but yes
I carrying red flags yeah so guys if you
want to donate the link is there in help
teach someone how to pray Salah uh yes
red flags bro they red flags they all
stem from I I think for women it's
factors that are external from her I
think her decision- making I think women
are always going to be programmed by the
masculine Essence that's around them so
if they don't if a girl doesn't have a
father she's going to be programmed by
um by the Culture by the media when
you're talking about match.com earlier
it's funny that you're saying it's
pretty much arranged and I'm thinking
about who's arranging it it's the it's
the Zionist that control those those
dating sites it's the people that um
behind the scenes that they they like
the fact that they can play and that
they can put their hand and manipulate
relationships that they're not involved
in if when it's an arranged marriage
within a two families it's the father
that it's the fathers that are in charge
and that's that's much better than
having like these people who have
nefarious intentions okay what about you
Flags a masculine woman big time red
flag what makes you like what what would
she say or do that you like this woman's
masculine I mean I just I I'm not I'm
not a homosexual so I
want alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah have you noticed why is it
guys who are big have this massive laugh
have you noticed these two the way they
laugh you can hear them from a
distance he doesn't want an androgynous
no I mean I want the opposite of
androgenous is like a manly woman yeah
oh okay right true I'm not I'm not
homosexual so I want someone the
opposite of myself you know what I mean
I don't want someone similar to myself
you know I want the opposite of can I
interrupt you quickly I think the reason
that you see the big guys laugh so loud
is the same we were talking over here
about how feminists they end up wanting
to be dominated the most like women who
act like girl bosses and shave their
head and have blue hair they're the ones
that really that they adopt those traits
yeah they do because when they're always
like looking for power in public they
want to relinquish that power in private
it's the same thing like when you have
like these big guys over here they're
like intimidating other people all the
time when they get time to laugh man
they just want to let it out giggle like
like a kid yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
interesting all right any other red
flags for you yeah um if she has like a
a weak father uh that's that's
definitely you're stealing
mine not her fault no I know but it's G
to it's going to affect her what you
mean by weak father like when I meet the
family I I judge the father immediately
and I judge the mother immediately so
okay that's that's quite profound so we
need weak father are you talking about a
father that might have some kind of
feminine tra because I'm not going to
lie I think you're on to something there
so if if there's it because if she's
used to seeing her mother take control
yeah this is very important yeah like if
if I'm going to meet the family and the
mother is doing majority of the talking
the father just sitting there
immediately I already know how she's
going to be like she's been trained by
her mother to behave like her that's you
know what they say my coach they say
look at the mom and marry the daughter
yeah yeah so if the mom is talking too
much and the dad's not even talking at
all that's a big red flag to me you know
I'm not going to lie that's that's
actually quite profound that's very
actually that's very quite profound okay
interesting all right that's I said we
have to bring the water we have we
have but you're right that's the
quickest way a girl is going to become
traumatized if she has to make up for
the her missing father or weak father
she's gonna big problem man she'll make
up for that missing puzzle piece in her
life big problem man is big problem and
uh another thing is if she doesn't
respect authority if she doesn't respect
authority then that tells a lot about
her you know she wants to be be in
charge she wants to be in control and
she doesn't want to be a woman she wants
to be a man you know so yeah you can't
do that man and mar mar a woman like I
can remember have you seen my video
confronting Britain first no so there
was this woman with the red hair she was
like a proper M masculine she's saying
some good stuff about Pap now well of
course she is yeah she is because she
she's she's she's anti-semitic now she's
anti-semitic that's why yeah she
she
you yeah yeah he just saying Allah cuz
we had the donation
look at that amazing donation brother
and sisters if you want to donate carry
on 100 pounds can teach 10 to 30 people
how to play Salah the link is there guys
inah please help donate I know you guys
are enjoying this you guys are watching
this we're going to get some callers in
a minute to see what they have to say I
think I know the feminist that you're
talking about she has the glass she's
like the archetypal feminist n there's
this other one yeah I was thinking to
myself imagine I go out I do da and I'm
confronting people like that and I come
home to another one like that yeah so
imagine to us and that's why I think
wrote a book he said it's so important
for a d to have a good woman because bro
it can Mash you up imagine you're
dealing with all those crackheads
outside and it comes to another
crackhead at home that's yeah bro it's
so fundamental for public figures who
are in the cause of Allah to have good
woman W it's so profound and it brings
the best out of you bro like my wife may
Allah bless her like we have ups and
downs I don't want it to come across as
like we have this honky Dory we have ups
and downs bro we have our fights
arguments like normal people do but may
Allah bless her it's because of her how
she makes my life easy that I can do the
things that I'm doing imagine I'm coming
here and I'm organizing this and I've
got another woman who's a rebellious
woman at home and I need to think of
this I don't want to go home let me have
outside do you get what I'm trying to
say it's very important uh for us to
have that let's get some calls how many
people
watching okay so guys about 2,000 people
are watching may Allah bless and
preserve you guys but W I would really
appreciate if we hit 30,000 before we go
because we're going to be we're going to
be going in about 45 minutes here we're
going to get some callers but pertaining
to the topic please yeah if you want to
talk about marriage uh that kind of
stuff please let
question for sneo for the Warner for
hijab uh inshallah please guys also
we're fundraising for the Salah plus
program which is to help teach new
Muslim and born Muslims how to pray
Salah we have this guided prayer mats
guided mats look we printing 20,000 of
these in Turkey by the way we paid
£16,000 pounds yeah we are printing
20,000 of these bro I wish I had this
when I came to Islam because I was
taught how to pray Salah in East Masjid
but you forget you have to go over it
again you don't know what he said you
said it right or wrong and it's not just
towards the mat you know it's not just
towards the
we also have Salah instructors imagine
imagine bro imagine the kind of reward
someone will get for helping someone
pray all the all the the teaching them
how to do wo yeah and not only that I'll
just let you guys know Aki we had a
Catholic sister call in her sister her
her husband is a Reaver so her husband
has an health issue he couldn't pray t
with standing so she's a Catholic Woman
calling the studio asking a question on
behalf of her husband
about oh she's jelle she's here yeah she
took a shahada but guess what oh great I
was going to say we just found that we
found out that her husband is you know D
D is one of our Salah instructors D is
the one who taught her husband how to
pray Salah and then she accepts Islam
and then we said to her look why don't
you use your husband's Sal she goes no I
want my own one yeah so may Allah bless
them she's here on the chat as well may
Allah bless sister jaelle she came to
Islam and now our sister seems teaching
her how to pra Salah for absolutely free
do we have any callers bro can we try to
go for callers that show their face so
there's no trolls bro yeah I want to
skip the trolls yeah please please I got
time for the trolls if let's let's get
the first call too hungry to deal
exact wow really told you n no no don't
get bro don't get anyone good he's fast
man this guy but it played on the screen
see I told you about
that you took it off good it was on
YouTube just now yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's what they do you got to
delete the live afterwards yeah yeah
yeah yeah no I always do that anyways
but yeah maybe we shouldn't take call no
don't get calls man forget the calls man
no cause no cuse someone played porn
they do that they they jeopardize the
life the whole Channel get the channel
can get yeah but it shows you know what
that shows me it shows me the power of
Islam do you know how many shows we get
like this bro so many people are coming
to Islam and we're teaching them you
have to imagine sometimes we don't get C
for two hours they are waiting there for
hours just to do that can you imagine
what kind of person you have to be you
have no life it's unbelievable but yes
because what they're trying to do is
when they play pornography yeah then the
channel gets like a community
you exactly ald we got some more
donations coming in of
£110 64 US Dollars guys let those
donations come in in slowly please
remember to delete the live after we end
no I do I do I'll put it on private
immediately no no delete it don't if if
it's on private they can still report it
oh is it that's how they got yeah oh
okay all right okay I'll probably
download it yeah okay so yeah um hijab
um how was your marriage seeking Journey
your was quite smooth man I think you
was quite smooth after punching your
legs honestly for me I I don't know
about all this um game and all this
stuff and I don't know about all this
stuff so for me it was just a a very uh
straightforward protocol was quite
similar to a job
interview so how did how did you come
across like like your wife was it from
family was it like it's from school from
my school oh okay so you went to the
same school yeah okay so I knew her
brother so I went to her brother and I
said let's uh let me get to know your
sister that's very honorable actually
let me tell you what actually happened
shoot apparently she wanted you know to
get married so I think he was trying to
Hint it in it so I was like okay oh he
came to you yeah so she had she had
interest in you or she was looking to
get married but he mentioned why would
he mention it to me unless there was
interest there I mean the man like this
I mean one second one second let's look
at their face come and zoom in
please so anyway um after that what
happened was um I said I was very I was
actually way more staunched than I was I
was more staunch then than I am now way
more strict like I wasn't like in terms
of Islamic opinions I was follow of the
hardest harshest opinions on every
single matter wow okay now I'm not like
that because it's very difficult to live
your life like that yes it is so for me
the proest C said if you make your
religion hard over yes I wouldn't
recommend my my Approach but what I done
and I was like 20 years old at the time
was I wanted to be very clear and this
and that and I went to the house and uh
uh if what I didn't want to communicate
with her on a WhatsApp group MH or on
any um anything like that because I knew
that that even yes even if it's a group
something could happen it's one step
away from being a private oh even in a
group yeah even it's I'm not saying it's
Haram I'm not saying I'm just saying me
in the way I communicated with her was
through emails okay and I CCD her
brother okay brilliant perfect into
every single one of my emails it's like
you know you put CC's and I'd call him
and say to him do you are you reading
them like I was very strict on this I
was very strict I wanted it I wanted it
to be like properly done I felt myself
I'm going to come into this marriage I
want to come
in great
blessings and um to be honest the good
thing about this is that it allowed me
and this was I was a young guy yeah so I
was 20 years old I didn't have any money
at this time yeah I was in fact I was an
undergraduate yeah so I was trying to
expedite the process because I've been
I've been you know holding myself for
many years yeah I was I was trying to
expc as supp make it quicker so I pushed
it and it's like oh to get to know
period I tried to make that as short as
possible I don't know how many months it
was maybe two months that's not bad I
knew her from school anyway same same
same my family I knew like I knew her
brother for years do you know what I
mean I knew her family for years so see
my wife I think it was two and a half
three months we was getting to know each
other yeah two for me I think it was two
months well okay yeah something like
that maybe it was a bit more or less and
then um and then uh we done to the we
got married and uh how was your C was he
like how was it was it big was it small
Mor so it's it's pretty they have like
multiple ones and stuff like that
and say that again jelle she does she
want to speak yeah okay we'll go to it
in just finish let hij finish and we'll
go to his jelle yeah yeah so it was it
was uh it was it was okay I would say it
was like a medium size is it wow M
medium size that's good man that's you
know I find that really beautiful you
know what because you don't have that
jilia you need to understand cuz we when
we come we come with baggages and that
can really traumatize and sabotage your
marriage because we come from this whole
different Paradigm and to come it does
for you to come and like for example
it's your first experience bro this is
why I believe marriages are breaking
down because men and women are so much
experienc in so many other angles you've
got so much to compare yeah but the
thing is there there are weaknesses of
it as well so like as a Muslim man that
hasn't had any experience of women in
the past yeah yeah when you first get
into a marriage like that what happens
is that you you don't know what how
women behave yeah like in a romantic
setting that well but every time you
talk ABD donate another
£400
abdah when you're talking all right
jaelle could wait let him keep
going so I'll be honest like in the
first I got at 20 so um it took me a
while to understand the nature of how a
woman behaves in a romantic setting
because I obviously I had experien with
my sisters my mother my nieces it's not
the same it's not the same there are
there are there are obviously flesh that
joins this experiences but I'm saying
that in general it took me on this like
what is this Behavior you know yeah is
this what is these mood swings what how
do I how do I Implement control how do I
control the
situation how much affection do I show
these are all questions I don't know how
to it's very true because if you show
too much affection it's it's very bad
very true but if you show too little
affection it's also very bad has to be
Balan when to show when to initiate
affection given when to remove the
affection given when to
uh how to show that you're upset yes
anger was another one because in the
beginning when something I yeah when
when anger was something like I anger
results when somebody when someone does
something that is against your
expectations yes yeah so if someone does
something against your expectations you
get angry yeah but so I used to get
angry and the way I'm a extroverted
person sometimes I'd ra my voice and
this and that get into an argument get
into a debate yeah I realized that that
was not the approach that you take of a
wife really yeah for me it's it's a sign
of weakness to get into prolonged
argumentation so I I didn't know that
you know to get into a prolonged
organization yeah and they say things
they don't I think I think so these are
things that it took me some time to kind
of understand the ropes of a proper
long-term marriage romantic relationship
in it and um you're still with the same
woman yeah yeah you got married at 20
yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's that's that's
that's brilliant man well it's it's so
profound but we're going to come to why
that's important as well let's get
sister Jazelle because she came to Islam
a couple of weeks ago let's see what she
has to say
inum sister
jaelle may pleas sister take care insh
so guys as you can see that is Sister
Jazelle this is real life situations
guys um her husband learned how to pra
Salah through our Salah instructors D
then she came to this show to ask a
question about Twi for her husband then
she accepts Islam and now inshallah
we've sent her guided prayer mat or
she's using her husband's one in the
meantime and insh one of our team's
Salah instructors will get in contact
with if you've noticed she said our
sister team have been gone in contact
with her and she this was about a week
ago why because there's such a demand
even I was chasing up another sister
who's like look when can I get the Salah
instructors this to me makes me so happy
you know why it shows people are eager
eager to learn so we want to expand the
team guys so we can have more sisters
catering to more sisters brothers team
to increase that inshallah because we
want to make this a worldwide Mission
the link is there guys 100 pounds can
teach from 10 minimum 10 to 30 people
how to do wo For the First Time how to
pray Salah and even Surah F we are
dedicating a Quran teacher every week
that people reverse of Muslims around
the world can tune into and go through
Surah F inshah so bear that in mind
inshallah uh coming back to our topic of
uh marriage we've got about maybe 30
minutes where we need to start heading
off to the restaurant the table don't
worry we're gonna make sure you you
don't worry about that at all yeah okay
you
don't you don't worry about that all
yeah so yeah you talk about Mar that's
that's really good man um yeah so um
learned a few things from that but you
know like one thing that is very
profound of what sneo said um which I
think is very interesting bro because we
were talking in the car about like the
red pill stuff yeah yeah and um there's
a book that's written I think we all
read it it's it's called rational maale
by rasi you read it yeah read yeah you
read that one yeah roas he's like one of
the figures of like the red pill
movement and one of those things that he
keeps talking about is how as you have
you interacted with him before yeah I
have he embarrassed him bro did you
embarrass did you the side of him that
came out like I truly feel like I don't
think he wrote the book based on looking
at the guy no way like it's like someone
else wrote I need to watch that bro I
haven't it's a funny debate it funny
really bro what was it on on fresh and
fit actually no but what was it about
like he was really upset with me about I
don't I honestly no it was the fact that
he was talking about um encouraging men
to get vasectomies saying a high value
man is rich childless gets a the sectomy
in his 20s I'm really against that like
I'm really Pro baby have babies like
that's that's the most beautiful thing
yeah get I think it's compare a
vasectomy to a transgender surgery you
know you're effectively you're changing
your your output and your purpose in
life so I'm really against that and he
was saying he was saying that it wasn't
like the problem with red pill is that
you could reverse it it probably said
but the reversal rate is like 3% or
something and it decreases as the years
go by the reversal rate lowers and
lowers and lower so it just don't get a
aect me absolutely there's no
circumstance the problem with the red
pill is they say that it's not an
ideology it's praxiology which means
it's like it's a response to how the
world is so basically in his terminology
is that's like a coping mechanism to
feminism that's what red pill is it's
just a response to how I know he says
that but he offers prescriptions that's
the difference like you know in usually
in ethics you know um in ethics if
something becomes prescriptive at any
point even if it's suggestive yeah then
it does become really an ideology now I
know he says it's not an ideology and
I've said but it is it is an ideology
because the moment you start giving
suggestions and recommendations is the
moment you start moving into ideological
thinking what you would call theological
ethics that's really what distinguishes
like say virtue ethics from theological
ethics it's is the prescriptive aspect
of it so so for example he's got these I
don't know what he calls them iron laws
or rules or something in the back of his
book yeah the iron laws of laws
right don't listen to that like like it
should like just look at him that's
that's all I just look at what he looks
like I have no problem with the guy like
I mean he's a he's a clever guy I mean
you can see from his writing style that
he's he's he's got intelligence he's not
it's not a fool but I mean it's just
claims like these which is like for
example a prology or ideology pra it's
not a pra It's actually an ideology
because it's prescriptive in that sense
the second thing is what you touched
upon today was really powerful because
one of the things I stuck out to in the
beginning of this book bro he kept
talking about this thing about body
count and I think it has permeated a
little bit bro into the Muslim Community
especially with Muslim men that there is
this kind of feeling oh we need to get
more and more experience with different
bodies and different women yeah there is
that idea and obviously maybe they'll
disguise it in a a marriage format or
whatever it will be but it's the idea
that you'll get more experienced you
become more confident you become
stronger if you have intercourse with
multiple ladies now firstly I was
looking at some of the studies relating
to uh casual sex and its effect on men
and women yeah there's there's multiple
studies on this by the way it harms more
women than men so that's that is almost
consensus can we get into that what are
the harms of that but it harms men too
like I know it's so it ruins this it
ruins your your connection and bond the
more that you have the this bond which
is a really emotional tie with somebody
the more that you just do it uh
recreationally you're not going to be
able to have a pair bond that's true but
I think maybe it's sneo they talking
about numbers of 20 30 40 50 of course
it's it's it's on a smaller scale the
reason it doesn't affect us much is
because we we are polygamous by Nature
that's right because we are programmed
to have multiple women it would only be
wrong imagine Allah is allowing us to do
that but at the same time when we do
that we are harming ourselves so that's
why it affects women more than men of
course it does men as well but it harms
women more than men because women are
monogamous by Nature all the studies
said that I mean all the studies that I
said said it affects it harms women more
than it harms men yeah every single
study I think there's that is one thing
the question of whether it harms men is
actually
controversial because some studies say
harms men like what sneo said some
studies say it doesn't harm or benefit
and some studies say it gives them more
confidence cuz you know why for us to
have intimacy with another woman it's
like for women it's like attachment bro
for us it means nothing but the point I
was making about casual sex thing about
this like multiple bodies and he I think
he says you have to have I don't know
sex with 50 women I don't know 50 he
says 50 I don't know what the arbit get
that number from I don't know a block
number or something like also keep in
mind America is very easy to get laid
like it's very easy
so anywhere world he would argue that
it's not actually that it's harder that
you need to be like especially if you
pay for it I guess yeah if you're a
certain type of guy espe if you pay for
it I keep forting well it's not
recommended in red and let's be honest
bro a lot of these s to say uh figures
of red pill they will go to an escort
just to increase their AB I think
they'll go to women who are pseudo
escorts and prostitutes and stuff like
that I mean dating is pretty much
prostitution it's not that far off it is
it is it is like you're exchanging your
time and you're giving her fun stories
and taking her out to a restaurant
getting a hotel you're spending money to
get in Sex and it's not with no
commitment it's the biggest fraud for
woman like imagine for a woman it's the
biggest fraud out there man you are you
know my teacher said this and I found it
like obviously he goes if you think
about they're like walking toilets why
because would you look look think about
when you need to relieve yourself where
do you need to go James suu something
like that no no no this is me don't
don't get CR to someone else yeah
this okay just think about yeah when you
need to go to toilet number one or two
you need to go to the toilet to relieve
yourself there are men out there who are
horny who are like I need to relieve
myself in someone yes and they are going
and doing you're treating these women
like toilets you're like l a toilet can
I just use you for a little bit okay
thank you can go now you are destroying
and dismantling these women like as
Muslim men we are told to be protectors
and providers not misguides and
destroyers yeah you're misguiding and
destroying this woman and then what
happens is I don't understand the cycle
that's why I kind of disagree with Myron
because it's like this Perpetual cycle
of um you know sleep around you D and
then you complain does he say the same
then you and
say I don't understand that priscu you
have a problem with I want a virgin but
you are causing then then again so the
question is how to what extent if any
what evidence is there that the
increased body count that you think
you're yeah is is going to increase your
confidence whatever it is that that's
going to lead to a uh more resilience in
Your Part B that you're going to be able
to deal with women in a relationship
setting you can even make the argument
of the opposite let me explain why
because if you're used to just getting
sex from women without having to put
work into a relationship yeah so now
when you're in a long-term relationship
and emotions become volatile and it
becomes a tempestuous situation exactly
so now you're used to just getting sex
whenever you want you're used to just
getting this and that it's all
transactional for you when you're not
getting it how are you going to react
exactly are you able to deal use your
prefrontal cortex and your hippocampus
rather than your amigdala which in other
words are you able to use those areas
and centers of the brain which which
operate on long-term Horizon thinking
he's not using his brain bro he's using
his private and a suppression of um the
sexual appetites no because you've just
trained yourself number one you've
trained yourself of getting sex whenever
you want of using women in a
transactional way of not working hard in
a relationship you will not value it bro
it's simple as that if imagine like
Donald Trump said you know my father
just lent me a million dollars yeah it's
like bro who would you respect more
somebody who's money been gifted to him
or somebody who worked his way up
and how you going to Value imagine
you're given this and that you're never
going to Value this stuff that's why
it's so important that you know like
even Allah says in the Quran with
hardship comes EAS this concept very
important on this point it's very
poignant because they'll mention people
like genas Khan or they'll mention like
conquerors of of the past there's
something which differentiates genas
Khan and the conquerors of the past je
who's paying for sex let's be honest or
doing the the equivalent of that which
is which is this yeah they fought in
Wars exactly and then they conquered so
they they first had to go through a very
difficult ordal yeah which is life or
death situation and then they collected
the war booty and had slaved women and
all that kind of stuff it's different
from and they had kids with them like a
lot of the the sex with women in the
west now they're on birth control you're
pulling out it's it's sterile it's just
it's kind of like H it's kind of like
gay SE if you think a lot of the guys
that when you sleep around with women
you're just doing it for pleasure and
you're not doing it for the function
that sex was created a lot we're
supposed to have sex to have children
that's the whole point and not only that
you get rewarded for it like the
companion came to the prophet peace be
upon him and the comp the prophet said
you get rewarded for uh having sex with
the wor he said really and that's why he
said it's a charity he said it's a
charity he said that's why I'm a very
generous
donor even more than
abdah abdah go for another one come
on so the thing is here alh in halal
setting so there's nothing wrong with
your wife yeah the point is this though
yeah I
the prophet peace be upon him said do
you not get a sin for committing Z he
said yeah then he said then how could
you not get a good reward for doing
intimity with your wife do you get I'm
trying to say because if one is a sin
the other will be a thing now talking
about kids I want to ask you guys a
question when do you think you should
have kids so let's suppose you got
married by the way uh how old do I look
first I would say well you said you were
verted uh 12 years ago 11 years ago 11
years ago and you've been married for
how
many quite a bit
yes now when the numbers start coming
yeah
34 yeah I'm exactly
34 but but they say I look 26 you're
what you I'm 255 that's for the CV
guys I'm I'm yeah I'm 34 I'm GNA be 35
in April is it yeah two questions I want
to ask you guys firstly yeah do you do
you both want second wives we'll comea
later but don't get in trouble please
yeah I second the first one when do you
think you should have kids so imagine
you guys got married and you're three
months into your marriage when would you
want to have kids I thought I would have
kids by now when I was um a teenager I
always wanted to be a young father I
thought that by like 24 25 I would have
had a kids now if you got married let's
say three months ago when would you
would you want to start having kids
immediately pretty soon yeah okay I
would say I would recommend what about
you for me I mean the only one of the
major reasons I want to get married is
to have children I don't want to just
get married just for pleasure you know
okay because yeah I just I want to get
married to have children okay I would
personally say do not have kids for two
years the reason being is because years
a long time no you you know why let me
tell you why let me tell you why yeah if
you if you marry look let me tell you
something you do not know a person's
true character until you spend about two
years with them imagine you are married
to an absolute shaan and you have kids
with them and you're going to see them
for the rest of your life yeah no no no
no no I'm telling you yeah I'm telling
you guys yeah if you marry somebody who
is absolutely a nutcase yeah this goes
for both men and women now you are stuck
with that person for the rest of your
life for the rest of your life and
you're going to have to see their face
and the kids are going to suffer and
then if you marry this woman by in
today's age that stop you from seeing
your kids that's traumatic and I know
men who are on the verge of suicide
because of this I disagree I don't think
it takes two years to figure out if
somebody's a sh what would you say rough
how long would you say I think you could
tell pretty pretty quickly really oh no
man there's some there's some good shans
out there that are I mean better
deceiving she comes from a good family
she's pure and she's on her de bro bro
bro don't let me tell you something one
thing sneo yeah I'll give you advice
you're reav yeah do not ever for for the
or the hij or she's let me tell
something do not do not ever let me tell
you something I from my experience here
oh she wears a hij she has a she says Al
does guarantee that she's a good girl
don't because you know why I fell into
that where it's like you let your guards
down you're thinking this time you find
out o like she's
um hi she's o you know mean she's she
she's some months just to see yeah
please and guys we are look we got we
got about 25 minutes to go we're just
under 2,000 away abd's going to
S know
abdah he's near 6,000 in
total sister okay so you're saying how
would you get to know if she's it's
pretty easy to tell if if a woman's a n
it's not that hard bro man it comes out
after the uh I don't know I don't know
is there any ways we can find out like
if if a woman or a man before or after
the mar during after after the marriage
dur Mar actually I have some I have some
advice regarding that for me I mean um I
believe you get to know people right
away through traveling with them so I
would say immediately when you get with
her go on a very long honeymoon and you
really get to see her through the
airplane rides you know you're a little
bit tired how she behaves in certain
situations you speed up the process a
lot faster when you travel with
individual you get to know very quickly
and all that you know facade it
disappears during travels it's good and
what are you looking for because for for
me the one of the worst things in a in
in a woman or a wife is a shamelessness
100% like actually a real put off you
know like what's your definition of
Shameless um so the opposite of modesty
in this case modesty is the virtue I
think shamelessness is the vice do you
know what I mean so if a woman is too
talkative with other men and stuff like
that it's a real put off it's a real put
off for me bro 100% because like that is
that's a disrespect to me brother yeah
for me a Shameless woman is the most
dangerous woman yeah a Shameless woman
that means she's willing to do anything
that's what the prophet said if you have
no shame do as you please yeah yeah
not yeah so when you see those
women out there that have no problem
like exposing all their body parts and
walk out like with just like a little
thing thing that that is we're not even
talking about that I mean for for me
personally like you know we're talking
about Behavior rather than the attire
cuz the attire would have already been
set you can fix the attire but you can't
fix the mentality the attire is a is
like a red line it's like if you don't
for me personally once again I'm a bit
more stored would be if you don't do
this and it's a divorce I'm not going to
be absolutely absolutely to say like but
that I'm not saying that should be for
everybody yeah some people will like for
example if a re came to Islam um and
she's taking time to get to you know to
that's a different situation but if
she's established Muslim you know it's a
different situation for me do you know
yeah I I'll be quick to cut it off too
yeah yeah yeah but um and so and when I
say im modesty I'm talking about this
kind of like the way she fraternized
with opposite gender if she does so in a
very immodest Shameless manner for me
the kind of anger that I can feel from
that dangerous levels of anger it's um I
wouldn't be able to live that we just
had a donation of $255 from two red
crime and then 173 Canadian from the
sake of Allah abdulah abdul10 us
Muhammed yuf 20 us and sever hundred so
we are we are nearly Target we're just
about
1,655 away easy yeah okay all right
interesting so we've got guys about I
would say 15 20 minutes more before you
have another thing is sorry to say dirty
if she's dirty hygienic most women are
hygienic most women are hygienic you'd
be surprised man oh sne tell us some
stories bro oh I don't want
to you've said
enough say no more say no
more that for me is a that me that's a
disqualified actually it's a red it's a
red card you get a red flag that's a red
card it's a red card honestly forget
that it's like you know um another thing
is
um rude but that one you know we got to
be careful with that one because when
someone's cantankerous you know wow
that's an amazing that slubber the
gullian have you heard SL the gulan no
panus huh you haven't heard of that
that's actually what does panus mean
cowardly yeah it's actually word someone
P USS y call him
aimus yeah and what was the other
one are different dictionary this no no
one uses this he the that uses this what
does canus is used by I think so
can cananas is someone who is overly
pical come on that didn't help
anything someone who like basically
argues too much okay but rudely argues
in a rude manner um if a woman does that
all the time is that is actually a
horrible Behavior bro sorry that is
actually you know you know one thing I
can't tolerate and I think a nor man can
is the prophet P upon Him is an
ungrateful woman and thing they make up
the majority of the Hellfire yeah okay
just give context it is true the prophet
no it's true it's true the prophet went
and he saw majority of them and he said
you he said use the
word yes which means that they are
ungrateful to their husband and the
companion said are they ungrateful to
Allah he said no rather the husbands
this is very interesting because he said
the husband would do so much good if he
was to do one thing that he doesn't like
he would say I've never seen any good
from you this is something I believe a
lot of women are they have this innate
it's just wir it's wir in that is that
is a thing about women in general that's
how they are because that's how they are
I know it might sound bad but it's um
that there is something in Psychology
called the big five yeah yeah it's it's
the gold standard of understanding of a
person's makeup and so on and there are
five traits trait you know openness and
conscientiousness and uh so on and so
forth but one of them is called
neuroticism neuroticism is when someone
sees the negative and bad situations all
the time okay it's linked to in
gratitude
has to be yeah so if you're if you're an
ingrate you're more likely to be a trait
neurotic yeah yes well almost all the
studies that I've ever seen yeah that
have looked at um cross-culturally
different women from different cultures
yeah have shown that women have a higher
degree of neuroticism than men wow okay
which it indicates okay so how is that
going to play out in terms of gratitude
it plays out in terms of ingratitude of
course so it's a thing which women have
to struggle just like men are weaker in
other areas yes we we in terms of
lowering our gaze in terms of sexuality
you
know the human being has been created
weak that's a verse in the Quran yes
that the human being has been created
weak the M the exist say about that it's
man is is very weak when it comes to
sexuality yeah man in particular it's
true that a human being but man in
particular we're weak when it comes to
sexuality so ingratitude is one of those
things you're going to deal with if you
get married yeah but there are remedies
for that yeah and that's and and the
remedies are remedies remedies for that
bro is um so I have these kind of things
that I do with my family yeah we bring
them all together we bro I I by the way
I'm going to start implementing that my
family because I think it's very
beautiful yeah for first of all let's
implement it for ourselves yes so we are
told to do on it like in means say
alhamdulillah so which means to
alhamdulillah you've heard it before has
used it and other people which means all
praise and thanks be be to God and when
I say alhamdulillah say for example I'm
think alhamdulillah I think about one
thing that God has given me so for for
example alhamdulillah for my eyesight
alhamdulillah for my hearing
alhamdulillah for this alhamdulillah for
that for this provision I've been given
uh research has shown when you do that
you actually get into an elevated
dopaminergic state it helps you there's
there's good evidence to show that when
you do that it's actually good for you
of course so the first thing I do is we
we sit as a family or with my kids and
stuff like that and I'll say to them oh
my gosh someone just made a massive
donation oh how much sorry forgive me is
Abdullah Abdullah Ali Just donated
£800
work he's much keep him talking keep him
talking we're going to get to the 30
he's he's much hypable than you in all
aspects
abah so when you sit down so we say
alhamdulillah
say Allah bless him he's given nearly
7,000 or 8,000 since we started like not
just today he's going in bro I told him
but this R because I go the ice bar I'm
going to present in the Ice Bar from
now so saying alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah now when I say
alhamdulillah I think okay alhamdulillah
Allah gave me family Allah gave me good
health Allah gave me this I was in a bad
position before Allah gave me Isam and
that puts me in a better position I said
to my kids what are you grateful for
it's a very nice game and it's not like
I'm absolved of it it's not I don't need
it now after we've done that that's
round one round two is okay tell me what
you're grateful for person B for so
because the prophet
said whoever does not thank the people
does not thank Allah so tell me what
you're thankful for me for and I'll tell
you what I'm thankful to you for cuz
when you verbalize it when a woman says
I'm thankful to my husband for providing
for me for protecting me it means so
much to us it means so much to us and
vice versa bro and vice versa so it's a
very good thing to do this yes with the
child with the family with this kind of
thing we've got to make sure that we
reinforce that so that's one aspect of
it and the other if it goes too bad
that's you should make cards of these
like games you said Muhammad hijab
family game yeah the second tier of it
in it yeah that be game you came up with
some good stuff I I want royalties bro I
want
royalties you got invest already don't
forget H game too if it gets bad if
ingratitude becomes bad yes then the
thing the best thing is removal s to say
so what do you so if someone is taking
from the room something is removal of
attention of the thing question so if
someone's taking something or someone
for granted you have to take that thing
away from them so they can feel how it
live how it is to live without it then
they start this is this is very
important exactly that it's like that
man gratitude is very very important
that's why Allah says in the Quran if
you are grateful I will increase you
yeah increase you in what a lot people
when they hear this Ayah they think oh
you know if I'm grateful for the money I
have Allah will increase me Allah say
Allah doesn't mention what he increases
you in it can be that he increases you
in more gratitude and if you're more
grateful the more you're happy you are
do you get it so it's very very
important guys we have got literally 15
minutes we're going to end the show
because we want to make sure the
restaurant on time the brothers are
really hungry 30,000 yet
oh we're literally 695s away bro yeah 6
don't be surprised ABD come a knockout
bro yeah bro bro bro he doesn't mess
around I'm telling you who else who's
the the guy the other guy the other name
Red Line something no the the second
person who is jaelle not
jaelle Russian oh um let me get the name
for you you're talking
about this guy out get the porno guy to
donate some
600 make up for the
copyright second you're talking about F
yeah fich fich
fic let's do it okay oh we're getting
close yeah this is actually phenomenal
five 5000 we need to raise 5,000 PS just
in a matter of a couple of hours guys
yeah may Allah bless and preserve you
guys inshallah so we've got 15 minutes
to go guys um is there any questions on
the chat bro maybe want ask is there
anything you guys want 10 15
minutes should we get callers or no
callers I think we already learned our
we learn our lesson you know and the
prophet peace be upon him said the
believer doesn't get bit from the same
hole twice so we're going
to got a lot of things to saying you
know is already I liked um I think we
need to exploit more of your insights
both of you actually when it comes to uh
this whole red pill discussion because
from the har world the the gender stuff
yeah you guys have got M good Insight so
we want to ask about that yeah I mean
women are not in the west are not ever
they don't show gratitude ever they're
supposed to not they think that their
existence is to extract resources from
men and then they get encouraged if you
listen to the if you dissect the lyrics
and all the music and if you look at the
the women that they look up to that's
that's all they brag about and it's not
even subtle anymore if you look at the
the main rappers that these girls look
up to I mean all of them are are
strippers first off if you look at their
concerts they literally just get naked
and they talk about like how much they
can get uh list lyrics are so explic I
don't want to repeat them but they brag
about how much they can get a man to do
they want to take
they see that as kind of power yeah they
they they are encouraging women to take
the power away from men completely
through financial extraction financial
and by using sex to like basically
they're bragging about how big of a
prostitute they are yeah oh this guy's
offering me this well this guy's I got a
birken back for this I got that's why
they hyper to do anything that's that's
the reason why they Hy the reason why
they hyper they do that to show off bro
it's like you know and the thing is if
you think about it I think that's the
reason why Allah subhana tala has set
the biological clock for a woman limited
not for a man because we don't have
those characters and it get it gets kind
of sad when you see I was on a podcast
with this um a Jewish girl um Sophia
Franklin she has a big podcast called
call her daddy and she was saying that
whenever she goes on a first date the
first thing she asks is for a man to
show his bank account to her I'm not
joking it sounds it sounds like a joke
and I asked her about it she was she was
dead serious but then it gets to the
point like she has a Birkin bag but she
has no children and then she's 35 36 and
all she can do is she can Flex these
material so at 35 this is her
requirement she's 35 yeah you know you
know you know where the delusion is
coming from sneako the delusion is
coming from put your hand like we're
public figures here we will understand
this I only understood this when I
became Ali dawa yeah because you need to
understand the psychology of a woman a
woman is sought after so just imagine
you are a guy that walks down the road
and there are girls just trying to
trying it with you you go to your
messages you getting messages from girls
left at Center you got all of these
women to pick from it gives you
it gives you a reality it gives you a
false sense of reality this is why women
have this entitlement issues you know
why because they think I've always been
sought after men have always been
chasing me women though look every woman
because of social media yeah the average
woman thinks like the famous man exactly
exactly yes bro reality every woman in
the west now because of Instagram thinks
the way a celebrity male does thank you
because they they get proposition as
much as like the most famous
mank yeah all kind of depend
but you know what you just said is
important that's why I said to you when
I became Ali da I got an idea from the
reality living because when you become a
public figure you got more sisters now
proposing to marriage my criteria went
from here to there because I was like I
have more options to pick from when I
was looking to get married because I was
like bro hold on a second I can get this
kind of sister I can marry this kind of
sister I went into this endless cycle
bro where I was not happy with nobody
you know why because I was like I've got
a pool of woman to pick from from
Marriage that I was and I thought to
myself oh my gosh this is exactly how
woman think you get into this pedestal
where you're thinking you know what no I
could deserve better I want oh decision
yes that's why when you asked me earlier
like what are the three things you
wanted that's why like I don't really
like like to think about that too much
because I don't want to get clouded by
things like oh she needs to be this age
this body count this like whatever I
just like if she fits into my life and I
fit into hers then I think that's the
best would you what about if there's a
sister that a non-muslim woman who you
find as characteris and she's like I
would't accept Islam are you open to
that that she won't accept Islam she
said she will accept Islam so she says
she's she's a western woman I've heard
so many women say that to me like in
Miami especially like women like yeah
I'll be a Muslim for you like all this
stuff for you no yeah I don't I don't I
don't think
that
me I don't even think I'm setting up the
zoom call right now you I don't even
think women would find Islam without a
man anyway I think they would only do it
really for a man I I especially I don't
think that women can have a connection
to God without a man explaining it to
her you had the man who the prophet
Muhammad explaining to yeah like would a
woman really pick up the Quran and take
her Shahar on her own ever that do
unless she's been through some traumatic
experiences yeah you mean like in
generally yeah they can like what do you
mean like can woman come to Islam
without a man do you mean well according
to the statistics more women are coming
to Islam than men I don't know if you
know that for every there's four
women but what you're saying is right
because that's the reason why a Muslim
woman cannot marry a Christian or a Jew
or Hindu but we are allowed to marry a
Christian or because they're become
Muslim exactly because we have the
influence a woman can be easily
influenced but even these women that are
taking their Shas they're still being
led by shakes they're still being led by
the men who are explaining it to them
they're never gonna find god without a
man they they need
they
yeah it's true in a sense because we've
got Prophets The all men no no no no but
but the is he's speaking from that angle
like from
Men the reason I bring it up is because
asking um what you mean like they need
some kind of a a masculine guidance yeah
they need masculine guidance and you're
asking like what I accept a woman if she
said that she wanted to become a Muslim
um to be in a relationship I hear that
like quite a bit but I don't take any of
it seriously because as soon as I say no
they lose interest in Islam so their
whole interest in Islam is just because
they want a relationship yeah yeah yeah
so yeah inshah I think we'll find you
man genuine yeah yeah yeah you know what
you need to do go for like uh like even
like my wife my wife was not a fan we're
going to send the CVS the mar mar CVS uh
send it to the bsh shft show gmail.com
inah and we will yeah they can the bft
show gmail.com if you send it I will for
it to the brothers at the same time
though I think it I see a lot of um
strength and power and ignoring that for
some time I spent so much of my youth
ever since I I turned I had that
pressure in high school like oh you're
16 like you're still a virgin like oh
like basically call me a wimp because I
was 16 and so I felt the pressure in
order to to commit Zena and spending so
much of my youth and in college and
afterwards like Ching women that was
like probably 95% of my time for the
past 10 years for a decade like
literally just thinking about women
dating them taking them out thinking
about them yeah thinking about like the
roster and all this like um and it's
just it's such a giant waste of energy
and time that I've noticed like since I
reverted and just focusing on what I'm
supposed to do in my work my output
level has multiplied by like 10 wow
easily so I I I would actually recommend
to young guys and I like what you said
like you should wait two years but I
would recommend like have like maybe
those two years to just focus on you're
supposed to do especially for reverts
who are coming out of that lifestyle
it's a good time to be able to reset
your brain and pretty much make wodoo on
your soul make woo from women you know
cleanse yourself of that and I'm
noticing a lot of of benefits and and I
I don't I'm not rushing into to a
marriage I obviously wanted to when I
was younger but there's a lot of benefit
into 100 as a re as well like me going
back then I would have never started
looking for marriage I I needed two
three years to myself to cleanse myself
of the bad tra I had from Islam because
I could have ruined somebody else's life
J yeah so guys okay we're going to end
the show in literally 6 minutes we're
just 528s away do you think somebody can
do that hij maybe speak to your sne the
Warner zers who showed porn to try to
corrupt usely to do
it how much we need 528 pounds to end
the end the live inah and by the way
that money which we're not asking you to
give it to end the show £500 can teach
anywhere from 50 to 150 people how to do
how to and remember so guys if you are
watching this for you guys the prophet
peace be upon him said the son of Adam's
Deeds all come to an end when he dies
except three ongoing charity this is
ongoing charity beneficial knowledge
this is beneficial knowledge and a child
that supplicates for their parents
inshallah so guys we're here inallah
we're going to be end it in exactly five
minutes inshallah It'll be phenomenal if
we reach that 30,000 pound Mark which is
500 and 28 pounds away we can have just
10 of you guys 50 pounds yes so inshah
it can you can you send um 200 I'll pay
you back hey no we'll take okay is that
cheating no no it's not cheating no it's
no you no it's BR sneako pledged 2002
200 $200 yeah um you said you wanted to
donate as well yes yes yes whatever you
want to donate okay may Allah bless you
guys W that means we are just 325 pounds
away so unless who's going but I've got
feeling I've got feeling ABD Ali bro
anytime I do this appeals yeah any
figure I mention bro bang bro literally
some people wait you abdah you
know literally I've got a feeling he's
probably typing down yeah so any last
how much it it's 500 left and we've got
literally um so the 200 you pledged it's
that I'll do the rest 3 400 huh I got it
I got the rest are you sure yeah okay
bless you okay
app can
I I'm hungry I
wanna let's let's start let's start
heading out in and sneo knows the uh the
struggles of learning how to pray and
sub Allah bless him he's pledged the the
remaining but ABD Ali will still come
but guys hope you enjoyed inshah if you
have any questions uh obviously the show
is finished now where can they follow
you R Rumble Rumble yeah yeah Rumble s's
watching you saw I just had $500 to give
away
so so when it comes to Mah you can
ask was it TR gmail.com what's the word
you use Mah the Mah is basically the
like a right yeah yeah so since you've
mentioned those donations you're going
to have sisters telling you they want
50,000 now for but don't worry you you
have a right to you have a right to say
no don't worry common in in the UK bro
don't marry UK the US they're more like
greedy is it yeah really because it
seems like there's not as much money
over here as it is in America yeah BR
America are Bing man Muslims in America
are Bing country anyways we're going the
live in guys it's been phenomenal
amazing may Allah bless the brother the
sneo it's been a pleasure we're going to
go thank you for having me appreciate it
always inah may Allah bless you guys
inshallah make Dua for us may Allah subh
accept our efforts get closer to him
this Ramadan and make it a new beginning
for all of you guys inshallah this is my
11th Ramadan first Ramadan first one
first Ramadan that's I don't know it's
been a long right how old are you 20 I'm
32 32 second Ramadan fasting 32 time 32
times Ramadan was a boy I was a kid no
you're still you're still a
boy till next
time carry and donate in the link below
goodbye don't we all get happy when
somebody Embraces Islam how many of us
have the time to dedicate to teaching
them Salah for the first time ever they
are left in the dark without any
guidance you are the reason for people
like Michael like Katrina like Trisha
like me start to pray five times a day
that's F I said M all due to your
donations brothers and sisters we only
need 100 people to give £00 £100 can
help teach 10 to 30 people learn how to
praise Sal and memorize Al fa for the
first time ever not only that these
reverts will be teaching their families
their wives their daughters and their
sons to learn how to pray Salah all
because of your donations the prophet
Muhammad s. wasam said when you you die
all your Deeds come to an end except
three ongoing charity beneficial
knowledge and a righteous child who
prays for you not only is your donation
an ongoing charity but also an ongoing
beneficial knowledge click the link in
the description below and donate
now